うーん時に今日はねまたあれです
いつも僕のドッキリ仕掛けられているその後輩が来るんだけど
持って国からね高等技術なドッキリ米見せようと大よっ
それだけあればできる今日はを網羅しドッキリですお前田添
執権したことあるか出勤無意識に無意識かは知らないですけど
ずっとおしっこに行きたいんだけど人に言えなくて
public 用を足すというスーツ心あふれる行動でございます
俺が小学校の時もね思わずしてた女の子とが入って行っ俺はそれを見てあぁなりたく
ないなぁと思いつつ実は1年前ぐらいコンビニで働いてた時暴行が誤作動を起こして
ちょっとベジしているときにちょっと
漏らしちゃったんですけどオーランっていうちょっと恥ずかしいことがあるんです
ではもうすぐです1時に後輩送るんですけども聞いて猫お礼と紅珠いない通わせるです
よ
普通になんとも言えない会話をしてその時に出勤
俺嫌い催すというそういう時量なんジョイ用のビンにある程度にもう
正面を入れておきますそういう感じですこれを得たしポケットに入ってるんだポケット
に入ってて
猫
はないと話しているうちに一度好きやらって感じてくれ
ずっとここかに入れても読みますかこういう感じですっ
こういう子
こういう感じですこれがもぞもぞしてパカッと蓋を開けると
あ
ごめん森ちょっと偉大なことをしてあいつのその尊敬する先輩の俺がな出陳という
知った8日したら合図は果たしてどうカバーするのかっていうという意味で
隠すとか寝ちゃ
ぜひ早速にもうクレーンで監視カメラ仕掛けて普通にそのになりますから大事なだね
多分で俺の演技力なんですよ
いかに高人格的にも明日海スパというよ
ん
まずぞ
9大丈夫前はもう包んで座何か
基礎的に寝起きでこんなんか寝起き感を出して証明するをは制定だ見ているができます
[音楽]
はいん
バリを取っ
しています
[音楽]
ねえええません
ゆっくりそうながすると思った
ブーブー
清瀬ねうんねドッキリしてくるとおっ+教
食いっ
にくびって貫かれた
数軒の矯正の一声
寝てくださった信用しないんですよの良い暇だってやりたかったイユルしまう
食べますかさあ食べますかそしてそう開けちゃそうそう
平和だねぇ
委員の世界に平和をまたですね
それでやろう
すごく人
によって動作さん
[音楽]
ございます
一方作っている
すごいそう
俺はやつを得た
ちょっと思いました
p そうだ2月 yra 愛
あああああん
そりゃいい例だろこれちゃんと+ございました
馬鹿らしいやすい5
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンてなにゃんだ何やるの
ましたーーー
外にあるぞ1それ
うん患者救世待って
言わないけど何に何時何
何それ残土フリーいっ
[音楽]
何誰に言えばいいの
ダークな部分
[音楽]
これなんだろう
はって何なにこれでは何どうすればいいんだよ
無事大成功
[音楽]
b 種
しています